mime avec 2m qui rime avec marcel
marceau évidemment le plus célèbre mime
qui a créé en 1978 une école
internationale qui ouvre ses portes au
public pendant une semaine
en ce moment les cours peuvent durer
deux ans les cours de mime les élèves
peuvent devenir comédien acteur danseur
audrey go again nous fait maintenant
découvrir cette école international du
mime au drame des coups frappés dans le
vide
la violence d'une colère sans objet et
puis l'adoration d'un être imaginaire
les élèves de l'école internationale de
mimodrame font leurs gammes japonais
américains ou russes
les jeunes comédiens viennent du monde
entier surtout pour approcher le mythe
marcel marceau
premier quoi avec monsieur marceau
c'était comment dire c'était magique
c'était ce qu'on pouvait pas imaginer
quoi cette école on les copies pas
marcel marceau en tant que personnage
avec un hack est blanc mais on crée la
démo dame comme on crée les arbitres et
du théâtre
evra revient à défaut d'apercevoir le m
le public est venu découvrir ses jeunes
disciples et admirer leurs balais
science yeux jusqu'au moment du temps se
remet d'une de fer et le coeur ça vous à
prendre contrôle digest l'expression les
discussions qui exprime la joie la peur
puis la tristesse
ici on apprend à jongler avec les
sentiments et la maîtrise de chaque
partie du corps est essentielle mais
également pour moi c'est la chose la
plus difficile l enfer transmettre je le
vois je vois quand je vois monsieur
marcel se voit tout de suite il a une
rue d'arles une france de liberté
incroyable et si marcel marceau tient
tellement à transmettre aux comme un
relai ce regard si intense il a ses
raisons que marcel marceau ne soit pas à
se disent tu qui un jour lorsqu'il ne
sera plus soliste à ce qu'il verra y
rejoindra le ciel où la terre est bien
que ça disparaisse
apprendre à dire sans rien dit confié à
sa petite troupe d'initier le grand
secret du silence comme un héritage
ouais